i'm really kind of concerned because now
i got to tell michael
about this boob reduction surgery you
know we already don't like the idea that
i'm going to have weight loss surgery
so i am sure that he's going to fight me
on this breast reduction but he is my
husband
so i gotta break it to him one way or
another
hey honey hey baby follow me bye
um i miss you and i miss you too baby
i'm getting ready to have the surgery
well i've been putting it on my mind
since
no i wasn't scared i wasn't nervous i
was excited couldn't wait to get here
and still
couldn't wait to talk to the dollars and
i was fine and then i woke up going
so i must be really nervous but anyway i
got something else to tell you
what is that
well yesterday when i was doing the
consultation for the surgery weight loss
surgery
uh
they they were concerned about uh
my boobs are way too big your booze
way too big yeah
uh what does that got to do with the
surgery well they sent another doctor in
there to talk to me
uh he's a boob doctor
and um he's from ghana
he's from ghana yeah i thought he was
you for a minute
i was like just staring at his eyes like
god daniel looks like michael
[Laughter]
and to have the consultation with him i
had to
put a robe on and de-robe
what that's the doctor he has to see how
heavy they are
feel them you know medically massage
examine them he medically
handled them
i'd like to pick on michael